there is some anti-marriage propaganda
going around on Tick Tock this video is
going everywhere I cannot ignore it any
longer if you're watching you can see it
if not I will describe you're only
listening I will describe what's
happening a pretty young girl nice
looking happy sheep puts an engagement
ring on on the wrong hand actually
and
every time she she puts it on she's she
sees a vision of herself cooking
cleaning being barefoot and pregnant
holding a baby you're working so hard
and she puts it down she says no thank
you I'm out I'm out don't need that
don't want marriage
and the thing about this clip
people are saying
on the one hand
this is not true this is not true that's
not what marriage is like at all
and on the other hand obviously people
on the other side are saying that is
what marriage is that's why you got to
flee and the reality of this clip of
this anti-marriage propaganda is
it's half true
it's half true in that when you get
married
you will be
cooking and cleaning and if you're a
good wife you'll be cooking and cleaning
and having babies and taking care of the
babies and keeping a home and you'll be
doing you will be doing all those things
some some are pointing out well you're
doing a lot of those things anyway even
if you're not married you know cooking
and cleaning at the very least doing
laundry yeah that's true but it's not
even
in the same Stratosphere okay when you
the amount of just laundry that exists
when you have even one baby
not that I know much about this it's not
like I've ever done probably a single
load of laundry at my house but I see it
see my wife my wife does a lot of it she
works very very hard but that's that's
true you do all of that
and there is joy that comes from that
the the real answer to this
anti-marriage propaganda is what else
would you be doing
and the setting for the video is so
perfectly telling here because it's it's
at a nice looking little brunch spot
that's where it is nice little outdoor
patio Cafe sitting at a table that's
where the guy's proposing and that is
the alternative
if you don't want to get married if you
don't want to have a baby if you don't
want to commit to religious life and
marriage isn't for everybody if you
don't want to consecrate your single
Hood to something greater than your own
pursuit of pleasure
then you're just going to have a lot of
brunch and you know what in at every
single discreet moment
the brunch is going to seem more
pleasant than getting married and having
a baby and raising a family
until it's not at all
until it's misery inducing and Until you
realize that the family is this
joy that that I couldn't even possibly
Express
so you get I get home from work
I've been on the road
I've been working hard my wife she's
been working very hard we sit down we're
just so bone tired and then the kids
come over and they they do something
that's like demanding more of our energy
and attention just like I can't go I
just want to sit and watch an episode
and I just want to go eat brunch
somewhere I mean and then your little
kid just says something or just looks at
you and just kind of giggles and smiles
or something and your heart swells up
it's so great what are you gonna do
you're going to do something in your
life
and so then the question becomes deeper
the question is is the point of your
life to receive a lot of pleasure to
feel really Pleasant all the time
or whether we're talking about material
pleasure whether we're talking about
pursuing your career ambition or
something like that or
do you have more of a verb do you have a
biological purpose
does your body imply a purpose
does the fact that you're a social
creature and a complementary creature
and that that uh in the words of Thomas
Aquinas human beings are pairing
creatures so men are for women and women
are for men does that
point you towards something that will be
more fulfilling you're right lady if you
get married you're going to work a lot
harder than you're working now as some
bubbly little feminist 22 year old girl
eating brunch that's true you'll also
live a much happier life
work is not the enemy okay sloth will
not make you happy
mimosas will not make you happy at least
not for very long right now right now
puretalk.com
you know a company is looking out for
you when they upgrade your service and
don't charge you for it
it's great news for new and current
spiritual customers pure talk just added
data to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but have not made the switch
take a look again for just twenty
dollars a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot this is one of
the many reasons I love Pure Talk
they're veteran owned and only hire the
best customer service team located right
here in the great us of a most families
are saving almost a thousand dollars a
year while enjoying the most Dependable
5G coverage in America
remember that you vote with how you
spend your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that do not support
you when you go to puretalk.com Knowles
you'll save an additional fifty five
zero percent off your first month
because they value you puretalk.com
Knowles puretalk Wireless for Americans
by Americans Kathy hokel the Democrat
Governor of New York she is not happy
with all the illegal aliens who are
making it to New York
after conservative Governors like Ron
DeSantis and Greg Abbott and Texas and
others have have passed along the great
benefit of all those illegal aliens you
know that that uh wonderful expression
of diversity which is our strength well
Texas and Florida they don't want to hog
all of that wonderful diversity for
themselves they want to pass some of it
along to Martha's Vineyard in Rehoboth
Beach and to New York and Kathy Hogle
says hey hey
we didn't ask for this do you think the
city may have dropped the ball somewhat
in dealing with this crisis over a
hundred thousand migrants arriving in
New York City since spring of last year
no the mayor has had extraordinary
challenges he didn't invite all these
individuals in I think there was an
expectation that not so many would be
allowed to come to the border that
they'd relocate in other states so no
this is nothing anyone could have
anticipated and it's been an enormous
challenge we didn't ask for this we no
one could have anticipated this
you literally asked for it you you and
Eric Adams and many Democrats who
preceded both of you in New York have
asked for it when you have described New
York as a sanctuary state
when you describe New York City as a
sanctuary City
that is
the same thing as telling illegal aliens
come here you're not welcome in other
parts of the country you are welcome
here please come here
but they say please come here
when they don't think that the Florida
Governors are going to help those
illegal aliens who generally don't have
a lot of money make that long Voyage
it's very easy to say please come here
when you're a thousand miles away or
more
because you think well these guys
they're probably not going to hop on a
Greyhound bus so it's going to be El
Paso's problem it's going to be Texas's
problem
until Abbott and DeSantis are chartering
flights then they come there and they
say wait we don't want this we want you
guys to have all the diversity okay
well that's the reality the reality of a
sanctuary state is this massive increase
in disorder and dysfunction and crime
and housing problems and all the rest of
it that goes along with it and I'm so
glad that that New York finally gets to
see that so closely boy what a great
clip that was now make sure you ring the
bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
show we'll see you next time